hey guys it's just eatin hanging out
here on the red carpet for the Grammy
Awards and I'm so excited I'm also
joined by Michelle Marie hi you are
doing a crazy live show today I am
two-and-a-half hours I was so impressed
i watch the one she did last year i was
like holy crap this girl is amazing two
and a half hours just doing live
interviews so I'm so excited to be
joining you today I'm really excited
that you're joining us this is gonna be
so much fun the Grammys always bring out
the biggest nights as far as fashion you
know I can't wait and I'm really excited
and we're about to show my YouTube
channel here some of the highlights I
got girls dress is so pretty so pretty
tonight Katy Perry rocked the red carpet
literally while wearing this Valentino
music note gown Katy I love you and pink
not actually wearing pink but she still
looks really hot probably one of my
favorite looks from the red carpet was
actually Paris Hilton when I first saw
her I was like girl you work it there
also beauty trends that we're looking
for on the carpet being able to pull off
a bold lip is something I'm so envious
of I always try and I fail but these
ladies look amazing with coral to
classic reds and you know what they say
the bold or the better me do they say
that it wouldn't be a red carpet without
a smoky eye I'm a huge fan of the color
purple so I loved all of the Deep
Purple's and some charcoals to kind of
offset the purple I mention I like
purple one of my favorite looks is the
all natural no makeup look
lots of rosy cheeks with a nude lip that
says hey we didn't try too hard
how about Bonnie McKee she looked
amazing I mean she definitely rocked the
hair it was a really nice slicked back
look which is really popular on the
runway
Colbie Caillat looks absolutely stunning
in her red gown she also had amazing
hairstyle that worked perfect with her
dress it was a messy updo with a fish
braid all the way up the back Taylor
Swift's long ponytail with messy waves
definitely suited her
so many amazing hairstyles I love the
super soft and simple looks Sarah wasn't
the only one smiling pretty much
everyone on the red carpet was everyone
was so happy and excited to be there and
really what's better than that I mean
maybe some pizza thank you guys for
watching let me know what your favorite
part was and if you guys actually
watched this live let me know what did
you guys think and if you missed the
actual live show it'll be on style hauls
YouTube channel
links in the description I'll see you
guys later I am home from the Grammys
and now it's time to eat pizza I had so
much fun at the show it was so awesome
oh my gosh and cake
[Music]